hallo hallo mein name ist zurück meine
damen und herren der beschützen fordert
spieler auf der ganzen welt
[Musik]
ich bin ist meine lieben freunde luca
der beschüsse fordert spieler auf der
ganzen welt wir befinden uns hier in
vorn was auch so allerdings nicht in
einer normalen battle royale runde in
der wir uns mit anderen leuten um den
epischen sieg streiten ich meine ich
gewinnen ja eigentlich immer sondern wir
befinden uns hier in einer custom map
also in einer benutzer erstellten
fortnight karte und zwar ist das eine
dropper karte das heißt wir können hier
runter geht in unsinn tod das ist nicht
das ziel dieser map sondern das ziel ist
dass wir hier durch diese löcher durch
falter ich schaff's einfach wie da nicht
manchmal frage ich mich echt wie man so
schlecht sein kann wie ich das ist quasi
das gleiche wie diese minecraft the drop
die ich früher auf einem kanal mal
gebracht haben jetzt habe ich mal
darunter zu fallen ich muss quasi
hierunter durch die löcher durch das
heißt hier wie jetzt stehe ich halt hier
ich wusste nach ganz unten kommen
und ja das ist das ziel das hier ist
level nummer 1 das heißt wir gehen jetzt
einfach mal hier rein und ich den
kabinen ich komplett bescheuert ja ich
meine es kann doch nicht so schwer sein
einfach hier durch das loch dk bin ich
bin mache ich falsch
ich habe meine brille nicht auf mord und
ich geh jetzt mal ganz vorsichtig
feuchte erst mal hier rein aber das okay
das ist möglich natürlich ist es möglich
während ich weiterhin klaglos versage
möchte ich euch allerdings auch über ein
neues update an alle unter euch die sich
mit fordert auskennen die selber häufig
dicker ich bin komplett wahnsinnig
bescheuert dumpfer basel dumm mit
scheiße attacke
schlecht ich habe früher neuigkeiten
mein leben freuen und zwar habe ich nun
auch einen zug und herren ich habe nicht
eine support wakeboard darüber geht es
darum dass man in fordern einen namen
eingibt und mein name ist luca und
diesen namen könnt ihr hier eingeben und
wenn ihr euch dann was im wortlaut shop
kauft dann bekomme ich davon eine kleine
beteiligung für euch ist dahingehend
nichts teurer also ihr zahlt den exakt
gleichen preis wie wenn ihr dort keinen
namen drin stehen haben würde ich würde
mich also sehr früh habe ich das grad
überlebt eigentlich hat man halt extra
nur ein leben das man direkt stirbt aber
ich bin der beste spielern fordert von
daher gilt das für mich nicht die fresse
du lappen ich würde mich auf jeden fall
sehr sehr freuen wenn ihr den support
creator code benutzt er gar nicht mal
dann schaffe ich würde mich sehr freuen
wenn ihr das war es mit meiner bildungs
fans sehr sehr cool wenn ihr als support
to create akut
ich finds sehr sehr cool wenn ihr als
support ok taktiker ich war durch hier
ist das logo oder von dicker ich bin
dadurch gesprungen ein scheiß lama
schneider vielleicht noch gegen gegangen
wie gesagt halt ihr da nichts mehr
irgendwie in dem shop gibt es keine
zusatzkosten oder so wenn ihr alt
unterstütze einen creator code luca
eingibt ich finde es sehr sehr cool dass
es diese funktion gibt bei dem spiel vor
neid weil man ich finde es sehr cool
weil man dadurch seine community war das
alter
ich glaube ich brauche da gar nicht mehr
darüber reden ich meine ihr kennt ja
alle schon die support creator codes von
montana black und von rewe und ninja und
tief jugend allen weiteren m ich weiß
dass ich jetzt nicht so die 1a fortnight
community habe ich meine ihr seid die
lukb wir sind halt
ja die luke ruhig glaube ich habe nicht
so unfassbar viele vor neun spielern
meiner community
ich war da allerdings dennoch cool wenn
einige von euch eventuell
darf ich auch mal probieren also erstmal
laufe ich jetzt hier so und dann springe
ich runter und evag das war echt
beschissen ja guckte das selber richtig
scheiße hey leute ich muss es doch
zumindest schaffen durch dieses erste
beziehungsweise durch dieses zweite loch
da irgendwie durchzukommen ist auch ein
ita hat kann doch nicht sein die sache
ist halt auch dass das hier wie gesagt
noch level 1 ist also wir sind nicht mal
ansatzweise in level 2 wir haben nicht
mal die zweite loch bisherigen gekriegt
jeder kann die map natürlich auch selber
spielen
ich habe mal den code von dieser map
euch unten die beschreibung gepackt
haben das ist der map code die muss man
bei vorteil dem kreativ modus einfach
eingeben und dann könnt ihr selber euch
an dieser drop papier probieren nämlich
jetzt mal ein bisschen langsamer
hereford trotzdem nicht geklappt abbauen
kann ich auch nichts ich gehe jetzt mal
ganz langsam hier vorn springen auch
ganz genau hier an der seite runter
genau hier durch okay aber ich glaube so
muss man vorgehen erst mal noch mal ihr
fett die brille aufgesetzt probiert
diesmal von dieser seite hier also wir
springen jetzt runter ganz eng dadurch
leute ja wir haben es geschafft durch
das zweite loch durch es liegt alles an
der brille haben zu wollen zu recht
altklug gibt den ein weil ich meinen den
westen fordert spieler wartet man ja
auch ne also wir wissen jetzt schon mal
wieder das ganze hier in etwa
funktioniert wir müssen hier nur ganz
ganz langsam vorgehen bisher habe ich
das ganze jahr relativ stressig gemacht
aber wir gehen jetzt einfach mal wieder
erneut runter hierdurch auch mein gott
vielleicht müssen wir auch gar nicht in
das fach durch sondern in das was
in das andere also wieder hier perfekt
an der seite runter gehen hier runter
springt das tier ja noch weniger ein als
bei deiner freundin monika halt einfach
deine fresse also robert im hintergrund
immer mit seinen bescheuerten
kommentaren und selber schafft er ja
auch nur ansatzweise das erst dicker ich
papa ich war schon wieder durch es kann
doch nicht so schwer sein mein ziel für
dieses heutige video war von beginn an
einfach nur das erste level zu schaffen
mittler das ding bei der minecraft der
dropper map das weiß ich noch das war so
dass man sich für den richtigen weg
entscheiden musste hier ist glaube ich
jeder weg gleich also es ist jetzt nicht
so dass man sich für den richtigen weg
entscheiden müsste sondern man muss es
ist nicht so dass man sich für den
richtigen weg entscheiden muss sondern
man muss wirklich einfahren
ich glaube ich muss mich im flug schon
um gucken wo ich wirklich hin landen
will sagt hierdurch erste loch hierdurch
zweite jetzt aber auf die seite derer
das ist so gott verdammt eng
daniel klapp glaube ich doch ich hatte
gerade seine glorreiche idee dass sich
erst hierdurch gehe genau hier durchs
loch dann hier und dann drehe ich mich
um und geht dann auf die andere seite
ich war ich das bringt halt auch nichts
wenn ich mir irgendwelche videos
anschauen was ist denn das für eine
abgrundtiefe scheiße hier ich habe mich
richtig darauf gefreut auf dieses level
und jetzt louis ist hier normalerweise
müsste ich gut drauf sein ich habe
morgen geburtstag neuer wurde die lounge
tim lukas schott morgen
ich habe mir gerade diese kordel voll in
die fresse gedonnert dieser wurde hier
lounge auf jeden fall morgen im lukas
shop um 15 uhr es gibt nur 1000 stück
also es auf 1000 exemplare limitiert und
zu jeder bestellung gibt es einen von
mir signierten schwarzen smileys ticker
also falls sie da bock drauf habe gern
morgen im luca shop vorbeischauen um 15
wurde und jetzt geht es weiterhin mit
der unangenehmen cacau 47 minuten für
die schon in dieser mapd aber ich darf
nicht so aggressiv daran gehen muss ganz
ganz ruhig an die sache rangehen man
play button befasst runter gefallen
ich werde jetzt mal von einer anderen
seite probieren und zwar von hier hinten
sonst bin ich einmal von darunter
gesprungen das heißt ich geh jetzt mal
bei der seite ob hier ein bisschen
anders klappt er mich jetzt hier ganz
eng durch hier ganz eng und jetzt geht
oh mein gott okay okay wir haben einen
plan
[Musik]
oh mein gott walther hockey leute ich
glaube ich weiß wie das ganze jetzt
funktioniert ich muss hier in dieses
mich hat wirklich seit langem kein geld
mehr so gepackt dass ich wirklich 50
minuten lang also hier runter und dann
hierdurch und direkt in die seite das
ist sehr gut dass es selbst
etwas dicker als ist doch nicht wahr
[Musik]
jedes einzelne smiley kissen an der wand
hängt gerade du bist so scheiße die da
hh auf 2000 jahre später
oh mein gott oh mein gott das sind dass
also das erste level haben wir nun
abgeschlossen das heißt ich geh jetzt
hier zeigt drauf und wir fliegen nach
muss ich da hin
aber ich bin sogar hier wird super wir
haben nun hier das zweite level
freigeschaltet meine lieben zuschauer
das ist ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so
schwer aus ich bin einfach daran vorbei
sagt okay ist doch ein bisschen schwerer
als gedacht auf jeden fall ist das hier
nun das zweite level
da ich in der roda teil jetzt gerade bei
einer stunde und vier minuten bin
dementsprechend euch das video an der
stelle jetzt auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat und
ihr wollt dass ich nächste woche das
zweite level dieser droppa matt mal aus
checke dann lasst einen daumen hoch
dauernd bei 50.000 daumen hoch
eine menge 50.000 daumen hoch ist
wirklich eine menge schafft 50.000
daumen hoch dann sehe ich hab da bock
drauf dass ich nächste woche der zweite
level hier von dieser drucker map hier
hochladen werden wie gesagt nutzt gerne
in lucka als euren support creator kommt
bei vorteile das würde mich sehr freuen
wie auch schon bereits gesagt morgen 15
uhr kommt dieser rudi in den shop und
jetzt
[Musik]